you know i got a lot of questions for
you
especially with the current times we're
living in and and a lot of my
conversation having with you is around
the constitution how we're protected
because of this paper that was written
and the angle i want to take is slightly
different because
look we we we're all following the story
sydney powell
giuliani hey you know
there's so much fraud being shown you
know i cannot tell you what we have here
there's so many things that we have
going on and then behind closed doors
you know they're losing some cases and
then you know folks are saying well you
have all this proof
show it to us why don't you just show it
to us there's no way in the world
you know biden won 80 million to 75
million you know trump's the one that
had 80 million votes
all this stuff that we're hearing the
part that gets me thinking is the
following
there is this concern that this is the
tipping point
election wise if a biden administration
gets elected
elizabeth warren is going to come in and
she's going to change the game
sanders is going to come in and he's
going to change the game with minimum
wage federal to 15 bucks and colleges
and all this other stuff that's going to
go on
how much are we protected by the
constitution
well uh perfectly if it operates but of
course the whole thing the reason we
know this is fundamental
is that there's an attempt to undermine
the constitution
uh just start with this uh this is the
most
there are two things that are the most
sensitive about the constitution
uh one is we're a purely representative
government that means the only way the
sovereign who's the constitutional
majority has to control the government
is through elections
and now elections are deeply
controversial and there may be major
fraud
the second thing is the constitution is
above all more than anything else a
structure says james madison a set of
arrangements and those arrangements
divide
powers among the branches and that helps
keep them in line
and they they can be strong and yet not
despotic
well today eighty percent of our laws
are not passed by the congress
they're passed in something we call the
executive branch
a whole new thing the administrative
state
and it's hard for us to control a thing
like that
and of course just look at the intention
to pack the court
right the the rule of law depends upon
an independent
judge who can't be fired making a
decision that may be contrary to the
vast
power of the executive in the
legislature so those things are all
threatened right now
and that means that that it is very
fundamental and you could
the people are at the cusp of losing
control of their government
so okay so then let's go back then it
says are there some flaws in the
constitution because when you think
about the court packing
situation and you saw pence debate with
kamala when
he kept cornering her are you guys going
to pack the court are you guys going to
pack the court are you guys going to
pack the court
and then she revealed what their
approach is going to be
she revealed the fact that they're going
to come out saying well you know let's
just talk about the judges that not one
judge is african-american et cetera
she took that angle which means they can
come out and say hey maybe we need to be
a little bit more
inclusive and have a you know diversity
in our
uh judges that we have so if today it's
nine
and a number you hear about is up to 15.
who came up with the number 15 that we
can't go all the way up to 15.
uh well the constitution doesn't say
uh there's been three different numbers
on the court one of them with six
it's been nine for 150 years it was
changed for the last time right after
the civil war
and i think the arithmetic is pretty
simple if you can
appoint six more that'll be enough to
get what you want
and uh so you know i think it's just
that
i think they're just thinking backwards
from what they want
no i get i get that part but what i'm
what i'm asking is why isn't it set in
stone to say
nine is it we're not going above nine so
you know it's gotta be five
four six three two seven but we're not
going above nine
why is there that uh additional 15
left there to say we can go all the way
up to 15. obviously we know what the
motive is if they're up 9-6
they get to do whatever they want to do
but why did we leave that out for people
to be able to one day take you to 15.
well the court was not supposed to be as
important as it's become
i mean it's the court is designed for
one great thing and that is
it is decisive in the particular cases
that come before it
and those set precedents that are worthy
of respect
but the other branches also have
constitutional duties
you know behind you is abe lincoln right
and abe lincoln the
republican party which was partially
founded at hillsdale college i'm proud
to say
uh they had a plan and the plan was
we don't have the constitutional
authority to interfere with slavery
in the states but we can forbid it from
going
anywhere else and that means most of the
land the
unincorporated federal territories and
that'll place
slavery in the course of ultimate
extinction well in 1858 the supreme
court
ruled that the uh constitution does not
give the congress any power to exclude
slavery
in those territories in other words it
cut the heart
out of the platform of abraham lincoln
and so he gave a wonderful speech and
explained the relationship he said
each of the branches has responsibility
to interpret the constitution as it
deploys its power
not exclusively supreme court ultimately
in a conflict between the branches the
people are going to get to decide
through an election
and and uh and then he went on to say
poor dred scott
who was a slave who sued for his freedom
because he was taken into a free state
he is a slave now and no power on earth
can liberate him
it's been decided in the final court but
the question what are the
powers of the federal government those
people can't decide that by themselves
and
uh and so but now we've written it in
stone
that they can and they you know they've
written the craziest opinions in which
they say that they personally
are supposed to personify the people and
the constitution
so it becomes more important now than it
used to become
and you know if they do get to pack the
court it will
hurt the dignity of the court but the
residual dignity that the court enjoys
will make it a very powerful move if
they do it
in you know sometimes in uh uh in in
competition or in war or you know
whether you go study i know you're very
very well read you can you you've read
the books that
many of us haven't read over the years
and i know you're a big churchill person
and you've studied a lot of these guys
even aristotle the bible all of it